kay is a variable so it could take on
different values I can find a
discriminant as a function of K so you
can see the e squared minus 4ac for this
particular quadratic is going to be
what's B squared K squared the minus 4ac
will be minus 4 times 16
so that means minus 64 there is the
answer to the first part that is the
discriminant as a function of K do you
see that I mean I suppose I could write
this if I wanted to use my proper
function notation but it's it's fine
it's unambiguous as to what it is okay
so now then this part 1 and part 2 I
think how do we ensure what value of K
do we select to ensure that the
quadratic is positive definite well this
is the way that I would write it for
positive definite what do I want to know
about the discriminant look at the left
hand side in all the different
conditions which kind of inequality do I
want all right yeah yeah no fantastic by
the way we can't say this right because
the positive parts already been taken
care of did you notice that because look
here's a right here so a positive we
already know this to be the case
I guess if they'd asked us for negative
definite we'd say you can't I don't want
value of K you're going to get you can't
get negative definite because it's
facing upwards okay but as they accept
we want the discriminant to the less
than 0 and I know what the discriminant
is what I'm solving like so this is
probably solved before this is a
quadratic inequality what shall I do
factorizing is perfect so I'm going to
get K can you recognize this is
difference of squares take away a K plus
8 we want that to be less than 0 for
such a simple function you can probably
picture it right you got two roots at
negative 8 and 8 so you can picture the
parabola in K squared right you want the
part that's below the axis so which part
is that
yeah very good it's between what chance
came by the way right it's between
negative eight and a left-hand route
right-hand route that's it you just
answered the question so long as K is
somewhere in here that you're going to
get a positive definite quadratic and
what I'd like you do now is you view it
your computed there already go ahead
pull open desmos let's see how quickly
this warms up so I can show everyone up
here as well and what I'd like you to
put into des mots is this original
function this guy here okay
including the K because once you press
ENTER it will prompt you would you like
to add a slider for K so do that let's
see if I can get there before you do
does anyone order there has anyone put
in yet you're still loading up like I am
so in case you missed that instruction
because you were writing something down
you're pulling open dead loss and then
you're going to put in this original
equation 2x squared - x squared - what'd
I just say KX plus 8 plus 8 yeah plus it
okay
mums that's not helpful oh well it's
just this equation part anyway so I'm
going to take its suggestion and add a
slider okay so when K is equal to high
you can't see it and I can't move this
over here what am I going to do hmm
I think I'm going to put this back up
and then just rub some stuff out because
you've um you've probably got this
amount of working now done anyway or
pretty close so let's just make sure you
can see now and then I'm not enough
that's all right isn't it yep so now you
can see for this particular value of K
well that's pretty positive definite
isn't it all the way up there okay now
we can go ahead and we can slide this
and what did we say we wanted we wanted
between negative 8 and 8 so go ahead and
shove it over to the left everything
looks good
oh that looks all right and then when
you get to negative 8 aha
it touches now is this positive definite
it's not which is why we excluded this
value right because lesser than and
there's no equal sign does that make
sense yeah so in fact that's the lowest
you can get and now I can as you can see
if I go past that that's not positive
definite anymore and I can go all the
way the other way and you get this guy
and again look right there at 8 is where
it stops okay
by the way I'll just quickly let me see
if I or just let this play I want you to
watch how the parabola is moving
as K varies which is as B varies you see
what's doing look at the shape its
tracing out weird huh that's correct if
you if you follow your eyes along the
vertex right in fact I'll do better than
that yeah
there must be here symmetrical yeah no
they're doing an initiate I not has that
heís not bad right yeah awesome okay
take that technology so you can see and
this actually can become super important
when we move into the next topic after
this which is called locus right the
vertex is tracing out a new shape which
is itself a parabola a different kind of
Rattler okay so anyway
we've satisfied the inequality this is
what we want so just think about what
kind of rules you want to distribute to
obey based on whatever particular
quality they're searching for does that
make sense